welcome the hustle walk on the street
come to the house welcome to the street
of Detroit
mmm-hmm welcome to the hustle
welcome to the hustle welcome to the
hustle
welcome to the streets of Detroit baby
baby
she tried hustle shitty addition to
Detroit hustle Chicago grind the Chicago
what about LA it's the Palm Beach hustle
West Palm Beach answer where I'll be
this weekend
are you there this weekend yeah Thursday
Friday Saturday West Palm Beach improv
oh god dude gets old people get off your
meds
some woman said that to me she goes
that's God's where I used to live there
it's God's waiting room I was like Jesus
that was my joke that I've had for seven
years d'etre yeah for seven years maybe
she's having Heaven's waiting room
heavens where Heaven's waiting
actually that's might would be what she
said she stole that you tell that old
[ __ ]
that I said shut up I'm not starting
this right man I'm sorry dude how about
old [ __ ] scallywag legs here left his
[ __ ] toffee hey delete does I'm sorry
I'm sorry after we look like your maids
bro I wouldn't be surprised if I saw two
Liat driving in his super expensive car
his new Qi wagon and thing is so sick I
wouldn't be surprised if I just saw him
casually dump a bunch of mcdr a whole
just each other later he take McDonald's
eating like a like just say it was a
happy meal I could just see him gone man
and just and just lazily letting it fall
like a little wooden throw it he would
just litter bug out litter but I can
wait til last time you sell someone
litter it's been a hot minute ah you
know what I saw somebody a week ago on
in Marina del Rey
how do yep and two older women two
[ __ ] older women little bets don't
give a [ __ ] bro and they were in a
Mercedes the long Mercedes in the [ __ ]
just threw all I'm sorry to call her a
[ __ ] but it's true
I know dude you have to start using them
okay I don't really use that word either
I know I'll Bend are using a lot so I
feel like [ __ ]
that's an English thing well he's I know
yeah
but let's not use our [ __ ] so this
[ __ ] says she just she littered she
threw she threw it out on the street I
was like what you know why why she's
leaving this earth soon she doesn't care
it's like when you rent in a house the
hole in the wall you'll [ __ ] you're
leaving soon yeah Davidoff says I can't
wait till I'm 80 I'm just gonna steal
[ __ ] what are you gonna do I saw an 80
year old steal candy I really did didn't
didn't report him he just reached in and
put a bunch of my stuff in his pocket I
was like I wonder what age you get like
that cuz you're seeing the earth seemed
Larry King like there's he just farts
now like he'll just be sitting there
white no dude look Google that YouTube
Larry King farting oh dude I don't do
just rips the loudest fart no [ __ ]
given no no because he's leaving this
planet so also Isaac what do you do
shame me on Twitter I don't give a [ __ ]
I was eating with my friend's
grandmother
there you go live look he's just what he
does dude you get Susser neighbor you
just gotta let him rip it hurts to hold
him in New York he's Robert Malley who
served a special interest shut up chin
to President Clinton for our of Israeli
affairs is now director of the Middle
East and North Africa program the
International Crisis Group
let's get first the thoughts of
congressman Rohrabacher on what you've
heard so far you see any any optimism
here a lot of people do don't really I
was thrown off to him to say about being
an aggressive having an aggressive
policy multiple ones there's you know
there's there's one of him ripping a
large one you just pushing dude there's
him ripping way bigger ones dude it's
just what he doesn't know you skip
certain age why are farts don't words to
hold them in weight mom or cut off your
farts turn no no it's so easy to mess
with all right Whoopi Goldberg rips huge
fart on the view where you got it
damn she didn't give a [ __ ] he looks
like Whoopi Goldberg view like really
loud at the workplace you ever sneak one
in here you positooni it's lame I'm
gonna do it dude she just you just get a
certain level or say [ __ ] it dude yeah I
probably won't be that way I'm too vain
now I'd never know you're not like that
at all never fart around my girl no no I
fart not me yeah I farted on this
podcast Jesus dude Whoopi Goldberg
Whoopi I do Whoopi Goldberg looks like a
fart er she looks like she ripped
someone yeah like a cheap yeah you get
older and you have trouble controlling
you
yeah Larry King there's a ton of footage
him just being a baby and just ripping
through the interview like what who do
something I'm 9 d I'm 9 to some dude
something what do you do is I guarded
what are you gonna do well one time I
told you I was with there was a couple
that was boring me married to is when my
wife is super embarrassed like you she's
like and they were boring me and I was
in a bad mood and I was like I did I had
just met them we were talking and then I
was calling and I was just like you know
I'm people were drinking and I was just
like you know what I go like this I go
you know what gay just to mix it up if
you have pulls that's a wild card she
goes all right guys your wife dude she
was I've never seen her get more red she
hid her hands what is the kid with the
guys they were this couple was like well
kept power through it like there you go
girls like it happens
the only time I've been super
embarrassed when I ripped apart was I
was staying at klopse house you might
you know club and with his girlfriend
she'd they were just she just moved into
his house and I was staying there cuz I
was in training camp and I was like they
were just like feeling each other out
and we were watching I forget someone TV
and had to fart so bad but I'm like oh
I'm not doing for them as a girl and she
was like can you hand me down like yeah
I want to go like this I go did this
[ __ ] went in my face yet so red I just
I wanted to die I wanted to die
yeah I won debate I think so you don't
want to feel like you know and she just
goes oh and then pretend she's looking
for something as oh well and I went I'm
gonna so just real climate I'm gonna go
oh I'm schooled I was in waiting for my
scene I kept having to run out come back
and I'm in the scene and I'm sitting in
the back room
and it's empty and then there's the
other set that's like with the window
which is my office and I was just like I
was like all right I gotta fart and I
pushed my butt out like okay short
shorts yes hard as I could I go yeah and
then I look up and a woman's on her
phone she was I just I wear I look down
like nothing happening and I ran away
I'm not going I can't I can't be avoided
oh yeah I'm so embarrassed it's so
embarrassing I don't know what that is
hilarious
I'll call people out to like from in an
airport waiting to board the plane or if
I'm in an elevator or at a restaurant
and so on Rupe just a terrible fart
there's hot girls round-off see I'm the
big dude so they're automatic like well
he definitely party here but it's never
me yeah so I make sure everyone knows
like this who did that are you guys
smell that and like yeah I can't wait
who the [ __ ] would do that yeah I make
sure that I'm kind of the fart general I
know on the fart general but you know
did that
I'm the fart general fart general bro
hey good weekend in San Diego dude I
love saying to you great club that
American comedy clubs it's like it's a
letter it's all they pack it in to have
14 people yes yeah
what is it 200 people it happens great
though man low ceilings super cool Club
yeah
great club feel that laughter that with
our boy Stevie blue eyes yeah I'm his
girl are you the entire time
yeah Stevie told I could talk about it
yeah
arguing what are you it's always our
it's kind of a playful argument with
them yeah you know it's never that it's
ever that mean-spirited no it's just
weird argue in front of friends though
yes and I tried playing the narrator did
not go well there we are
here we always sit on some beer how that
beer was super hoppy and I I don't drink
that much although I'm gonna bring this
podcast to a screeching halt because I'm
tell you I drink an entire bottle of
wine last night okay yeah I did
it's called menage tois French wine
anyway I was drinking that beer at the
American comedy club it's real hoppy but
it's a San Diego Bay I don't know where
they got it but I get like allergic to
immense watches all did you notice that
swatch almond well I I don't sighs drink
a beer I've never seen your dad see it
seen you drink a beer I don't know how
long I know I don't drink I dive stopped
basically I'll have wine but even that
yeah you don't really drink one you know
what man I shot dois means threesome
bros right buddy men there's that wha
hey man menage a trois
I don't do French for a pee here guy
four years of beer oh yeah Japan I'll
see you sweetie beaucoup Hamo
nothing nothing I can read a lot of it I
say Apple what's an apple a bud I can
read a little bit of it but I can get
away I can get like I could get around
France for sure I can't wait why would
the Montreal were it's all French and I
was the narrator no it sounds like you
could Jenny Bunn sq Cheever de pomme de
terre what's that what's you all wanna
go to the pool no I don't know I'm
friends I said no but very good clothes
do you wanna go to the pool ask you to
vote you put the palm to death
do I want to go eat on the tear very
very wrong now listen I said do you want
some potatoes Oh
koalas dude that's a weird thing to say
there's a weird thing to say but it's
also figured you know dude so uh last
night I shared a whole bottle while my
dad had something like girl had a little
bit of wine that I finished it all you
know me I never drink so I'm moving my
dad came over to help me move and I can
tell he's like in a somber mood I'm like
[ __ ] my daddy's ready to go like he's
always you know high Sparrow mic was
wrong with you
and he goes have you talked to it which
I don't my dad's one of 13 there's a
shitload of shops all over this world
right I've whole bet on it I don't know
a lot of my cousin's stuff like that
he's like oh well your cousin Denise
well I guess we were close growing up
her daughter who's 12 now I hit by car
and and died oh so she goes to my middle
middle school and then her brothers go
to Overland and they go there in the
same area where I grew up in and I was
like oh dude oh my god it's your life so
I was in that close with them with that
and I'm trying to think the last time I
saw and that's his brother
that's his sister's daughter's kid so my
cousin my niece so I was trying to think
I thought I saw him and then I was like
why no I was like Jenna and they're like
yeah I'm like what the [ __ ]
starting around last time I saw her she
was four cutest little thing ever and
you know I not to disclose to mature
families fallen on hard times I found
out they weren't getting like Christmas
gifts so I wouldn't bought a bunch of
[ __ ] for their family this is a long
time when I brought it over there like
PlayStation all stuff
I remember her then nothing last time I
saw it yeah so I found out I was so
[ __ ] district is that I think it's
worse cuz I have a son so I started
thinking about how their free feeling so
I haven't talked to her me when you have
kids you realize that oh I called her up
I called her up man when I was
waterworks
yeah the waterworks my fish entire
bottle of wine of course well I was in
Thailand and the woman that was our
guide when I was doing hangover 2 she
like took you know if you wanted to go
and see the like the fish market ever
was or there the muy Thai Stadium and
she had lost her six-year-old boy like
you know in his car accident and you
just like I did not have my kid my time
was that age you know I can't fathom the
thing yet the weird thing too is when
I'm talking on the phone a lot of my
family's really religious you know me I
don't i'm not i'm not religious dude i
believe in a higher being but I'm not
like balls-deep in the Bible and stuff
and I'm my reasons but there are super
religious when I'm talking to the way
they handle it like up some right I'll
do yeah I used in so I used to be
jealous of guys almost firing football
all when I'd be so nervous I'm like how
the [ __ ] you still coming it's up to the
big man baby I'd like damn that must be
yes so we want to talk to my cousin
she's like you know it's just God's
calling at a certain time and if I'm
like a you out your [ __ ] mic what are
you talking about
she's 12 yeah she's telling I hit by a
car and died well that's not this that
if there's a Jesus he's not letting her
live her full live like that's torture
yeah but there's a meaning to suffering
right so Christianity has a sort of a
what's the word sort of a road map in
which to deal with this grief your faith
for sure and all that stuff and people
find great sells I always say that man
like religious comp religion and things
like that and faith come from tragedy
they don't come from comfort you know oh
there's a book called mere christianity
by louis CS lewis he also wrote the
Screwtape Letters classic and he he was
a Christian right I didn't grow up I
didn't go to church or anything like
that but in that it's a series of
letters that he wrote and read on the
radio to the British Royal Air Force
when those guys during World War two
when those guys go through [ __ ] they
were dying right literally left and
right and it's [ __ ] you like you go
oh that's a different take on
Christianity there's there's a reason
the Bible and the Quran and these books
in the Old Testament of around for I
don't know twenty five hundred seventeen
hundred three thousand years there's a
reason they had do have something to
offer that they did to just dismiss
religion out of hand
no it's nice it's nice and they have
structure yes yes yes I was just as I
would been a hot mess on a fakey
volunteer was like you know what's God's
plan and I'm like oh my god
inside I'm good what the [ __ ] you could
[ __ ] love but it helps them [ __ ] yeah
man [ __ ] yeah I have I've never that's
why I'm super respectful of religion
because I don't hate I've seen too many
people who had to call on it when when
when they didn't know where else do I'll
get them through yeah man it's like yeah
this my thing though if you're in the
Satanism if that's your thing that gets
you through I don't give a [ __ ] what you
as long as you're not sacrificing other
humans but right I don't critique
anything a goat
yes whatever you want man yeah well we
are all in one way or another religious
sometimes what else about their atheism
you know yeah well she doesn't believe
in it there's people religious about
conspiracy thing yeah you know it's like
it's something they can latch on the
human beings are naturally really just
they want to believe in something
well sure sometimes they'll believe in
in communism they'll believe in whatever
it might be you know they were talking
about how in in Russia you had a
communist sort of essentially what would
be like a priest who would make sure the
soldiers were up on their communist
manifesto and on it's the same [ __ ] but
Christianity seems to have a lot of
wisdom in it I know there's things to
criticize about it but it's it's got a
lot of power and wisdom he criticized
anything let's move on from that dude
the stake I had in sinning it was did
you get to try that I had a little buy T
buy yeah it was a tender stud do
anything for that steak right now yeah
that was that was at Graystone's they
still never heard yeah my boy Greg
hooked us up with that it's been around
20 years I guess all the reason years
yeah well those restaurants sometimes
they come and go on that Street on Fifth
Avenue but that place Cindy is a weird
vibe man it's a weird vibe to make sure
of freaking military frat boys football
players lot of aggression in jiu-jitsu
hot chicks yes alcohol yeah it's it's
you can get I love it quick I love it
but I don't hang out after hours yeah
well Pacific Beach and things you don't
ya PB as the kids call it's nice I'm a
peb I'm a PB yeah yeah dude that steak
my mouth is watering for tonight I liked
your new [ __ ] too how about that tried
some new material you would do I know
time to start writing a new set yes what
I'm trying to do yep I do I'm doing new
material night Comedy Store next Tuesday
all new material and then Neal Brennan
has the place here on the west side
which just new material night every
Tuesday night I'm gonna start doing that
we're at the Westside comedy yeah that's
a great I'm gonna start doing that yeah
it's great like Tim it's a new material
good yeah it's a beast of course it's a
beast now better and it just reveals
itself as you keep doing yet and in a
way it's almost for me no other way to
write but to be on the road like that
that's and that's why I'm doing all
these Road gigs it's a first of all I
love it but also it's it's gonna be it's
good to be back mister
right I've been on the road see I'm a
copper well I'm a [ __ ] cop I miss it
when it like when I'm in the thick of it
I'm like good god I just wanna be
homeless and then now I'm like I can't
wait for Miami you'll do it for you'll
do it to the rest of your life it's
great do it the rest of your life
because there's something about just
trying stuff you've done it you're alone
you're creative you're thinking you're
you're all it's so hard to compete with
that and you're experiencing new stuff
city people who do thing less for me
remembered you know my brother who's my
tour manager I don't bring a comic on
the road so I mean me and my brother so
it's away from me my brother to hang out
yes and then we explored the cities it's
the best you sell shirts and make money
I work on my craft it's [ __ ] great
yeah it's it's really hard to argue with
it really is it's really hard to compete
with it's to me it's like the whole deal
it's the best it's the best key the best
day you know what's the best gig in the
world and you control it you're you're a
rock star cool how about this sing the
same song for the rest of your life and
also by the way being a bus being a bus
but you tour live the money with five
other guys and and be with five other
guys all the time enjoy that [ __ ]
sitting together on you want to be a big
rock star private jet cool you're even
closer together
yeah Radiohead was talking about that
it's like we've been singing the same
song for Taylor Swift they had been on
tour for one year one year dude with
without a lot of bricks I taught you and
I you're close but you put us on the
road for a year together we kill each
other I mean well you and I could
probably do the B find our ways we'd
find our way to you know but we're in a
different [ __ ] during the day we break
down I mean you're right though it's not
easy it's like what how do you notice
something hurt it yeah
how crazy is it she's a she looked
pretty girl mish I see a person she's a
pretty girl I never she's very nice
that's Jin's number one really probably
in the turret very nice person too you
mean as a singer or everything no as
area no I asked he has a lot of personal
where their skin is number one you want
to be with Taylor Swift or do you want
to be Taylor so that's the question do
you secretly dress up like her songs
chin would you rush the load in Taylor
Swift absolutely would you if she said
about a girl I know it's super
aggressive I just wanted aggressive I
don't but I want to see where he's at
sure it feels like no I take Goodling
and she's a very
very very nice Lassie yeah classy yeah I
mean talk about popular yeah Josh geez
like what she's a monster
any good way I'm stretching stretching
on my back doing what drive a little
lower back Sandiego dude depend what
time of the day you go you're gonna hit
some traffic do you gonna hit some
goddamn traffic you'll sit in that
traffic my new test you sit there for a
while uh yeah
three hours not on the way back oh there
was an accident on the way back and way
back was sad open i sat for 20 minutes
do I like you man I love driving my car
so she only could drive it for that long
that fast hot cast listen uh yeah listen
um balls deep in the armchair expert
with that Shepard I love that podcast
Miley it's so good I want it so good
he's doing this movie I'm he's doing
this TV show and he was at the ABC
Television Critics thing and I wanted to
go say hi to him but I should have many
so talented
yeah he's a cool guy and it they they do
it from like a attic I think it's in his
house looks like an attic but they don't
do video which I don't think he gives a
flying [ __ ] I love that name armchair
expert it's so good man it's such a good
interviewing reel so good I relate to
months so much stuff that's why I think
I love them
really what's he talk about I've heard
nothing I have friends who know him
really well and they love him yeah he's
just he's a dude he's a great guy he is
he's a car guy big car oh yes yeah real
big car guy gearhead yeah Ferriss he
does him live too and you know he does
he sells out like theaters and does
these news live then he records them
pretty interesting yeah listen man could
ax [ __ ] up huh yes it's like a goddamn
gargoyle I'm also a stylist and also get
your [ __ ] out of all the fans face I
also do a lot of I do a lot of
meditation now dude
so I'm uh I'm on top of a rock yeah so
I'm super enlightened I'm really
centered right now
you seem centered thanks buddy um did
you watch the fights well as you saved
you watch the fights and the Grammys
didn't watch the Grammys you watch the
Grammys
didn't even know they were on oh wow I
should have they were interesting
especially cuz Drake was like this award
I mean [ __ ]
cut him off no basically he's just like
that now this means anything he's like
this little war doesn't mean anything
they kill him on I was telling you that
I watched The Voice kids 11 year old 12
year olds I've got a new show I think
it's a new shy don't think so
I think a young kid happened to be on
the voice I have not no I'm telling you
it's kid it says voice voice kids I'm
telling you dude these kids just sing
like I was like what the [ __ ] is going
on here what am i what is going on here
listen Swayze kids done 18 the less is a
voice kids that'll blow your [ __ ]
four years ago though okay skits are 12
years old six months ago
there's one kid who sings hallelujah and
I was like um oh my god put there but
I'm talking about 12 year olds
oh this is in England
[Music]
okay she's older she's older I was 18
yeah I'm talking about girl I'm talking
rule 11 and 12 year olds who blew my
mind this is not we're gonna watch oh
wow they all like to though yeah yeah
but but let's go ahead a best-of voice
kids
427 million views chin 137 the best of
The Voice kids yeah I'd imagine we're on
site something to do we don't have this
here though yeah it's in the UK how you
look this up bro my daughter was wise
okay this is a kid singing yes sir dude
I'm telling you I'm not making this up
I'm talking about 11 year olds who blew
my [ __ ] mind
why don't they show her
Jesus Christ you see and what 30,000
[ __ ] gave us the bad give us thumbs
down
this is Persian this is from Iran nice
tip I think this is the England one but
she's purchased huh by the Bell out
there yeah
[Music]
my
damn she sounds like Demi Lovato
I show the girl I know while I doing
this it's so strange they don't show the
person especially wood because they have
their backs to the [ __ ] kids did I
you want to see your heart now it's fast
forward a little bit
maybe not all the way to their chin
we're gonna watch this kid dude you
gotta look well now we don't know what
the [ __ ] ball let's go back to the
one then here she is watches nope
it's okay that's not that's a different
family bro look at how beautiful she is
that's her is it just that Freddie
Mercury mouth big old mouth
Jan I gotta know what that first thing
you're looking at all I think there's a
picture of them no I think that's why
they put the little image in the bottom
that's the kid there and that is he
scared of crowds or something
oh so annoying is this the kid you're a
friend - what's that is this the kid
really friend now now it ain't the kid
on the furniture no it's not but go
ahead and fast-forward so we can see the
little ones I mean that girl can sing
her ass off but but she's still older
ice the voice though you know so they're
all gonna be pretty good this is from
four years ago yeah this girl looks
young braces
here I mean she's killed yes that Anna
Kendrick's I keep going Jack Jack you've
gone he looks older she's 25 I was 27
[Music]
she's 19 so I'm not I'm not kind of like
all right whatever six-year-olds watch
the ski
[Music]
I bet he's gonna get all the girls that
looks like you that's how you dress yeah
Brendan's job as a kid yeah but I don't
a my raw don't move like [ __ ] oh yeah
sure you want to but you can't I don't
let you dress exactly like that yeah
well I don't see oh my god it's a little
Brendon shop dude all right so this is
awesome but can you go this is fine The
Voice kids can you got the voice kids
hallelujah you should get over the kids
thing huh all right you gotta see this
it's a young cute thing the other class
times Hey
it blows my [ __ ] mind there you go
that is tough to argue legend Daria's
areas there is Sabra Carter performs
Hallelujah here right there watch this
watch this you son of a [ __ ] I was like
what that's his grandmother no [ __ ] it's
a crowd was his sister watches two buses
find me a better voice crab and he's 12
how they not turning around look at this
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I mean obviously he's very special
but I mean what the [ __ ]
12
such a hard song sense
ooh how's the third day I get up turn
around way it's all dramatic babe they
do this this [ __ ] blows my love
[Applause]
[Music]
what [ __ ]
dolly does it and so by the way I have a
theory on all this these kids have so
this guy who works at Juilliard which is
the the performing arts school right
like Alabama they usually you exactly
you above all some instruments acting
ballet everything he said back in the
day you'd have one person that would
stand out now you have kids that come in
they're so [ __ ] good all of them yeah
that that back you got five years ago
five years ago they would all gotten in
now they have to pick one or two have to
why too competitive too competitive
Brendan why cuz there's so many good
because they're watching each other yeah
because the end there he's a secret yeah
yeah and it's like roger bannister when
he broke the four-minute mile they're
like no impossible that same year once
he did it for other people follow them
suit it's like it's fascinating to me
the human beings like when they see
what's possible they can do it yourself
asses everywhere does the Instagram man
dude you don't bring it down to ask what
I'm talking about some high arch in yeah
that's that's also but it's also
responsible for depression too cuz kids
get a new G Wagen then they see [ __ ]
Kylie Jenner posters she's like what the
[ __ ] might not do depression and suicide
Rogan had Jonathan Hyde on depression
suicide among boys and girls skyrocketed
it's like a it's like a Roman said that
craft looks like a BMX jump ramp because
of like social media what is one of the
things that Harrison and all that stuff
in a get you man and also we raised our
kids to here's the other thing it's
talking about what you appreciate we've
raised our kids after kids started
getting abducted in the eighth 70s 80s
in the 80s and the 90s it was real crime
and a lot of kids got abducted about 100
kids a year get abducted by a stranger
so it's very very rare slim the
vanishing but there were high-profile
cases what happened was parents started
keeping kids inside and kids were never
and still are never allowed to play
unsupervised anymore they're on a
playground you have a monitor of course
when kids are playing so they don't work
[ __ ] out together what that does is they
become really good at manipulating the
authority figure to their favor number
one number two because you don't give
kids stream the it's not true it's it's
it's it's ultrix and manipulating the so
when you have a when you have an
authority figure you can always go to so
kids do really well say like oh he hit
me like Tony yeah when you have a group
of people kids a lot of times work that
[ __ ] out you want to avoid bullying like
god I can be very damaging but for the
most part kids work their [ __ ] out on
their own there becomes like a hierarchy
but it finds itself kids are not being
allowed they're also not being allowed
to have unsupervised time and figure
[ __ ] out on their own because they're
being told it's dangerous stay inside
that creates a lot of for whatever
reason and according to Jonathan Hyde
who's a social psychologist and I looked
at all the data it creates a lot of
anxiety and depression and children
because the world is kind of a dangerous
place so and they're not able but but
more importantly here the abduction is
down well but it was always down was
always it was always a very rare most
done yeah and and thank God but what I'm
saying is that it's it's interesting
because stress stress for a child and
and and well stress for a child to an
extent is good like your immune system
you learn how to navigate you learn how
to when kids are mean to you you learn
how to not make the team you learn how
all these things you have to as a human
being you're gonna and what what seems
to have happened is you have a group of
adults now who don't really know how to
negotiate the space of you know failure
and things like the helicopter pants
right yeah and now lawnmower parents
that's the new thing what's wrong they
just move everything out of your way all
the obstacles out of your way hello yeah
and that's the new term but it's [ __ ]
happening
and it's not getting your kids ready you
knew there was a problem get rid of
dodgeball
right no my kids getting picked on sick
but wait exactly and that's one example
so you know luckily we still have sports
and [ __ ] that can help but it even then
in LA they don't keep scores and some
that seem [ __ ] ridiculous I hate that
stuff all my some planes not real like
I'm playing this little soccer league
used to and if we don't keep score is
I'm like I do what one not thing yeah
that's one not thing you guys help you -
thank you - I had the world's kids keep
scoring your winner you don't - [ __ ] off
no poppets shot was keeping school thank
you yeah I had to of course you do
MVP here yup he gets it done my favorite
thing is also this he goes he goes um
what was the what was the expression he
said I wrote it down who's like um you
you know
it's self-esteem giving a kid
self-esteem it's not it's it's
everything but not not just unearned you
don't just say you're the great no
really he's capacity and building a
skill it gives you self esteem and self
love it's not just good when you it's
because when you just give it to him you
said the kids amazing and he hasn't done
any what happens is it's unstable
unstable but then the kid has these
expectations then when he doesn't
fulfill them he goes I feel like a loser
I'm still my mom's face so I'm gonna go
shoot up a mall
exactly exactly that's how bad goes and
why do you think every [ __ ] mall
shooters a white male who's depressed so
so by the way also stories give me the
next [ __ ] when people say there's no
difference between boys and girls is so
[ __ ] hilarious they don't look at
science because they're idiots but uh
but that's the ideological left-wing
buddy buddy he said that so boys when
they're depressed and sad they they'll
take it out of others they'll make other
people's different girls self-harm they
do cell phone but boys ultimately boys
will kill themselves yeah suicide is way
way more prevalent in boys it's [ __ ]
weird man the differences in psychology
but he said he made the point yes
keeping the kids inside to keep them
from away from abductors and things and
the irony is you're doing you might be
doing way more harm on a wide scale it
has to be a balance there of course yes
anyway mmm [ __ ] count how'd your play go
that Brian didn't make I know but
remember like what I'll try wasting your
time you wasted that neither one of us
were gonna make you know I would've
though I want to reel this guy for real
would I would have come see you for sure
I would have supported you I swear to
God
well thanks it went well yeah there are
certain parts where I felt very
uncomfortable because it was a lot of
white people apologizing for race and
I'm like no I don't want to be here no
because it was like based off of like
little monologues that people wrote
about their experiences with racism so I
was like the Asian actress who did all
the Asian ones and then there was a
white lady who stood up and apologize on
behalf of white people and it made me
very uncomfortable yeah there are some
people who are clapping that other
people really
it's embarrassing [ __ ] yeah just I love
how people think that we wouldn't be we
would we
wouldn't have aggression dominance and
exclusion if we were all one race you
know cuz the Middle East there it's
really peaceful there how's that going
how's a frico they seem to be all of One
race sub-saharan Africa they haven't
been any worse at all what are you
talking about human beings find reasons
to [ __ ] you run cat yeah it was fine a
good experience are you gonna do more
place maybe ro depends on really my
schedule maybe not that one mmm yeah
maybe maybe nothing surrounding race
from here on out with the chocolate face
and this like maybe you stay away from
raise two for two
yeah would you do chin not much man
nothing no cream I know nothing ever no
Korean barbecue you still know same
place still over the same place now the
new place oh yeah I didn't know your
mood yeah my my lease ran up for the old
place I just bought another we're not a
bot but renting another place in
downtown yeah I thought you were gonna
get out of there it's it's whatever
reason I feel more inspiration there so
that's why I like it even though it's
more of a drive huh you're more drawn to
the downtown life yeah look if you're in
a tall building you see the lights and
stuff you're inspired downtown's
happening
yeah that's boom and oh yeah there's a
bar called the wolves that what it's
called the wolf dinner sounds will be
amazed wolves some really Zoltan of our
boy Pablo has a great family yeah yeah
we should more this great restaurant
dama dama down sister Cisco you don't
feel creative in Venice now a man really
well loved art and everything the prices
here are not that great either there's a
sense of yeah downtown a stone to go up
to though yeah but I get a bigger place
and a nicer place I think in downtown
you feel more creative for your songs
and [ __ ] you said just even a video
editing video when you when you're in
that atmosphere
it just feels it works don't worry yeah
somehow that video put out though what's
up what's the last video you did I don't
even remember why that last song what
you won't do for love you know old song
from Bobby Caldwell no play it is on
your Instagram um no but it's on the
YouTube but I'll you guys don't want to
hear that yeah we do you want here
ginseng right after hearing hallelujah I
sure do
what you want to do for love is that
that old-school song you'll do anything
no yeah it is that one oh yes
and then our that cart hoodie in there
too are those are in sale yet so why'd
your house pink make sure you that's not
friend studio okay you know the song
right you're [ __ ] right I do
it's that panty-dropper bro
[Music]
ooh
[Music]
Thank You Mass
I came back
[Music]
from your love
that headphone cord is stretched to the
mat it's tough man very good voice hello
Cheri I didn't see that one you put on
you Instagram I didn't either
that's one I father why you put this on
Instagram I chopped it up I can't follow
you - you did yeah I guess you guys just
don't write down for the inspiration I
always do that yeah yeah the hoodies are
on sale they're gonna be on sale this
week something you did cause it only has
3,000 views about what I don't have that
many subscribers but still this is you
jammin yeah a large Korean man singing
this lets get that let me get one of
those hoodies dare you write post I gave
you what already yeah I was here you
didn't get Brendan one two and it's been
sitting here since like three years ago
that mine no I gave you you took it I
don't worry about a Ryan - I've never
seen it my share what do you think it's
not true yeah it's all I would remember
it no promises yeah but you didn't give
me one
I did a medium yeah I medium it's pink
though I was like yeah I'll say you're
not gonna wear pink though you're like
I'll wear our you like you don't worry I
told you I know you guys I'm not gonna
wear I just know but I would have it I
don't have it I don't know what happened
you probably wear that I like pink like
oh water
I'm positive you didn't give me one do
you made it give to hit one think about
it I gave you both at the same time
you're wrong it's not big deals I think
I forgot cats play for one is that an
extra-large that's that's tough Brendan
like he's probably not gonna wear
anyways I didn't argue it you've never
got it I swear - sighs I said that's my
right there I'm leaving it going I want
to wear I will wear a face my shirt
coldest days everything I would have
remembered when did you give it to me I
don't know was a long time ago I don't
make this more awkward than it has to be
yeah you would think about it remember
because I would have remembered
otherwise I'd have it it would be in my
car or something it's probably not a car
it's not because I
Nucor I had to clean my car out where
the [ __ ] sweatshirt dude you
pretended you need get one at least I
have the balls go yeah that's my left in
a clump right have a bear that's so rude
you through you I do I should we want
tell us who the [ __ ] I bet you mine
watch this watch this
oh I bet you it's right here Oh Brian
it's not there yeah there's it's okay
Brian it's probably in your car oh well
there you go looks good on you ready
Brian doesn't about but I like it
thanks for wearing it I like mine cart
you didn't know my god do you know what
the shirt is my god unbelievable
you told me come on right Garth yeah
remember it feels like you're like the
Asian Garth yes I said Brooke it's very
comfortable it is super soft looks nice
well you had one and you threw it away
you'll find it somewhere give him
another one find it because I would have
had it okay you burned it remember your
cold Lynette it's definitely not in here
or Jordan from chin gsj no Brian keep
act like you're concerned by this hoodie
and look for it for the whole podcast
make it worse on chin may get more
embarrassing for him yeah me too girl
I'm not you know I'm not curious about
if it's in here yeah it's Friday night
here doing away and I'm super warm down
grateful for you guys threw it away well
we wouldn't throw it away oh my god did
you see the fight I sure did I thought
interesting civil looks really good me
too
I really did I thought he looked
fantastic I almost almost like the old
Anderson in some ways he was standing
there slip and shot he look good yeah
there's that style Bennet outclassed him
just like uh he's just a better version
of Anderson he's younger just
just better better or just faster
younger better more skills real got her
yeah better fighter
that's just sold you know like he they
kids when he was fighting you know he's
great but now benders just went oh
that's what you do well cool
you're my hero so I'm gonna download all
that and I'm gonna take it to another
level right you just it's just like you
know it's like the Anderson's the first
version of Tesla and [ __ ] bow benders
the newest yes that's that's totally
fair yeah and Anderson was doing like
he's the only fighter I've ever seen her
desk kung-fu blocking no he's doing it
just like it's kind of cool to see
though I know he was stating I got it
and used it before yeah where it
actually works but there you just shown
up I mean it's entertaining fight very
much so very much so I thought was great
um you see any other fights anymore name
someone else on the card Gil couldn't
name one person there you go let's move
on I can't either
I didn't you yeah um style bender has
some people in his way Luke Rockhold who
else
well Luke Rockhold's at 205 now oh he
moved at 205 yeah um
Yoel Romero Yoel has a fight against
Costa who is next for style bender who
would you like to see him fight depends
how long Whitaker's out to fight Kelvin
for interim title mm-hmm Weidman mm-hmm
Chakri Wyman Jacare mm-hmm we just need
to see what style benders wrestling is
about he's been doing for a hot second
you know he's not like this new kid
that's what people forget true
you got Brunson was a wrestler starch
them mm-hmm Brett Tavares kid Russell
starch mm-hmm yeah long he's the real
deal
yes yes let's see him but didn't dare
until at 8500
I'd love to see that yeah Wow you stare
until flirtin with going up to 85 yeah
he's gonna go there but he's gonna fight
again at 70 and then probably go to 85
who will till fight at 70 here's a fight
already
Oh Gunnar Nelson
think another wrestler I think that was
the last one right
pretty sure to get her nose uh is it
gonna necessarily Colby no not Colby who
the [ __ ] did they give Oh Maz Badal
sorry oh yeah yeah whoa [ __ ] that's a
great fight that's a great fight
Maz we don't give a [ __ ] that'll be
really interesting Leon Edwards for guns
right associate each other for some
reason yeah
Maz but all tills a fun one mm-hmm boom
I'm excited me two men oh we're gonna
fight conveying the Sunday breaths and
Gamow Cain Velasquez yeah we are
it's gonna be fun at cards stacked
stacked I can't wait you do exercise
Sunday night Sunday night it'll be great
perfect you some kind of engine we got a
few yeah anything fun there's some fun
ones in years yeah so the feds found a
shipment that was in Long Beach set to
go to Australia of a 1.3 billion dollars
worth of drugs most of it is ice and
that but there was also heroin it was
also nice I'm not my street another
former meth oh wow yeah they were all
packed into things that looked like
stereos and it came out to 1.7 tons of
drugs why would they ship all that at
once that's all they said they must've
been getting away with it
it got linked to one of the largest drug
syndicates within the Mexican they
didn't specify which dude I don't know I
mean whoever's doing it is but they
found it back in the end of genuine
January and the news just broke now that
after their investigations happening
they arrested six people to American two
Americans and then the other four
weren't specified Jesus Christ yeah
you're gonna wait for that to border
control he's going away for a hot second
I just I would imagine moving that kind
of product right in the billions
yeah well meth heroin those are not
marijuana's different you know someone's
no someone died for sure for [ __ ] up
a delivery someone got murdered for sure
yeah well 1.7 billion dollars in product
when you're a major crime syndicate
though you're being watched by everybody
so chances are I think now what'll
happen is they get those six guys and
then they follow the money and you know
how much do you want to talk you wanted
to thirty years you want to do six six
okay cool
now you're going to witness protection
oh good that's later oh sorry I got
excited you see one I got excited I said
that one hey you know what hey I like
you Brennan cuz you got your nose out
still when Brennan gets his nose out his
nose doesn't hit it doesn't get off the
ground until he finds his prey I stay on
it you stay on it like a bus like good
old bloodhound a bus that kid yep go
ahead and go ahead and you want to jump
to Domino yeah I don't care let's no say
that one let's say that one okay what
else you got so there is an Indian man
suing his parents for giving birth to
him without his consent makes sense
because he was born he has to do things
like get a job pay for rent loser and so
now he has set him yeah fake beard
it's definitely a fake beard it seems
like he's a bit of a troll because he
set up a Facebook page about being a
anti-natal list which is like you need
to give consent be given consent by the
child this guy's hilarious look at him
yes is your parents have a toy or a dog
you owe them nothing you are you are
their entertainer this guy's yeah this
guy's a comedian and he's awesome
England when she had met me before I was
born and that if she did she definitely
would have had me both of his parents
are lawyers and they are taking this
very well it seems like it's all a big
joke yeah like he's a huge troll and
that he's actually trying to get a
lawyer to defend him and see if he could
get a judge to a little waste of time
but at least
the marketing out of it what else he's
crazy
so people are dragging Adriene by long
for this video that she made where it's
a tuna sandwich recipe just watch it
tell me what you guys think that all
together already sucks some fruit punch
oh so as you can see I have a problem I
was home one day in high school I had to
make myself an after-school snack I made
myself tuna fish and I was like this
this is not wasn't doing much when she
was like I was already I just had really
high-end taste buds with a really low
class budget how do I create something
that is just amazing and just my friends
is what I created then just wait for it
it's coming and no one can tell me that
doesn't taste bomb you either can either
like this that's frustrating No
Oh Baby Jesus I'm not funny who wants to
fight come on I mix that all together
that's amazing what do you she has
nothing to do and she's probably high as
[ __ ] when she was in high school she's
not a good cook it's like it's like you
know I mean like ah hey man I want to
marry you can I get some cold tuna with
a lot of what half a jar of mayo yes I
would good tuna sandwich I do now you
put fruit punch on the side we got
ourselves a goddamn picnic uh-huh but
mixing them she was saying she's using
that boy the girl ban right yeah she was
in cheater girls she was a Disney kid
originally she was also in the band 3lw
she used to day Rob Kardashian all of
you heard Rob were super serious then
she broke up with him right yeah she's
revealed on her talk show she's on the
real that she climbed through his window
because she knew that he was cheating on
her and then like one off on him that's
why they broke up well well now she
makes where's Rob cheating on her with
black guy
people think it's a Rita Ora actually
well that's right because they were
dating right after so hot I don't know
oh really good god
Albanian girl for fun treat she's
Australian is she pretty sure she had
that picture of condo or shield really
good does she look familiar no no not a
good fan is she not Australian I think
she's from the UK is she yes I think
she's English all be Albanian I like her
even more she's what Albanian oh
fantastic is she curvy uh she's meeting
with Connor Connor is all wifed up on
her there oh yeah hey dude you got your
hand on her hip relax bro she's on his
lap what's up bro he's got a lot of
backlash for those from yeah people
really cuz she posted it up saying date
night
then he's assi married with children car
come on man Connor Kevin you couldn't
look more guilty that he's just Christ
he's a hottie though man yeah all right
what else we got to say the least
she ain't seeing her ass off too
so a lot of people are now boycotting
moocher because they came out with this
sweater that resembles chocolate face
what were they thinking I don't know
what they are thinking you're gonna have
a backlash with trolls and people who
are like this isn't okay with me this
makes my outlandish do I have a feeling
it's half blackface oh my god that is
terrible oh it's hilarious did you try
pulled that down huh right you know what
my bed the comments were hilarious on
that Wow
Katy Perry got some backlash for some
shoes that people are saying look like
have you seen her black faces [ __ ] man
so historic like because she slit eyes
and nose on a black know hysterical
about race user you're racist uh-huh
those are blackface shoes and she got
[ __ ] for it that's hilarious
scroll up cuz there's because there was
a tan when I have a tan shoe - so cute
I think Katy Perry's so hot I mean shut
the [ __ ] oh that's a tough one yeah the
[ __ ] shoe they're ugly shoes horrible
also shut the [ __ ] but it's black white
green or did to actually read lips so I
guess anything with black with red lips
is considered blackface then yes if
those gold lips would be different these
are hysterical people who are looking
for anything and they get points they
get brownie points for pitch finding the
[ __ ] you know the racism everywhere
that's like the the this guy's job and I
did this thing about the Longo and the
Philippines there is on Rogan again yeah
there are there there are indigenous
tribe in the Philippines so guess what
how they get brownie points
well you become a man to go into this to
cut a head off caught someone's head off
here and so when you go and you fight
another tribe you cut their head off and
you come back and now you're a man now
by the way sometimes there isn't another
tried to fight so what you would do is
you'd cut somebody if you had a fight
within your own tribe it might cut his
that off too it's what's called a Sikh
culture and it's what's called you know
crazy but he was talking about how when
you can't find somebody when you look
for somebody who's a racist or any
racism and try to attack them and get
them it's kind of like the same thing
you get brownie points it's like you
know you're attacking somebody and
hopefully you can look and hopefully you
can ruin their career you know hopefully
you can get him out of that what else
you got
it's cause I just terrible Jesse one so
the thing I thought was Jesse it's just
Jesse Jesse small it small its neighbors
casts doubt on his story
there's nothing has happened two weeks
knew the two weeks after Empire star
justice mullet claimed he was the victim
of a racist homophobic attack cops have
yet to identify any suspects and some
people in his Tony Chicago neighborhood
are growing skeptical I don't believe it
happened the way he said it did you know
it's really busy bragging Mohammed who
lives in the same Swank high-rise they
say it's mostly gay people and black
people in our neighborhood it's all gays
in black so it's not like sorry half the
people are gay the other half are black
wouldn't be the exception there Joe
Biden put it on blast - Joe Budden did
mm-hmm he goes hard in the paint yeah a
lot of people were criticizing him
because they said as a black man you
should be supporting other black if it's
wrong no that doesn't make sense like if
he said he just wants to see the footage
ya know shut up yeah I'm with him cops
had said they have found plenty of
survives video but none that capture the
incident hmm we are pleased yet to turn
over the data from his cell phone and
verify he was on the phone with his
music manager he was I heard they had to
subpoena him cuz he wouldn't give him
the records Wow sure that and then
police heard the rumors our police have
their doubts and they said that if he is
lying he's gonna have to pay for
finessing up well more also more his
agent said he heard small let's say of
the assailants shout a racist slur they
just want to know if he was even on the
phone with him yeah and at 2:00 in the
morning
was he were you on the phone with him
and he won't even turn that over that's
where that's where I'm like I think
you're full of [ __ ] I see dicey I think
he's full I don't believe it no there's
definitely if definitely we offered
watch go go back because and he
expressed he couldn't be without his
phone for several hours
I wouldn't want to be without my yeah
that's the thing
watch me up my phone several hours but
if everyone's calling me say it's fake I
might kill my phone [ __ ] there's my
phone
do we features yeah and then give him
the phone I'm skeptical here boys me too
so skeptical and tied a rope around Eck
in an underpass they punched him tire
over his neck um you wanna see this one
I liked a new trailer for Aladdin I
loved the music
I thought was a little odd looking but I
love the music you know the bit my
biggest issue is is Jafar should be
older and like deep voice they'd be like
the sex or something he's not can stupid
I don't know why they did that and
there's way hotter Jasmine's but
whatever it played for Brian's never
seen it I'll definitely be seeing this
the first side it comes out
this is the new Aladdin yeah with Will
Smith as the genie whoa
bring me the lamp
what is that your life begins now
who is that Jafar Aladdin
[Music]
jeanny wishes land none of that ringing
about interesting right you weren't
feeling well Smith the genie it's tough
because Robin Williams is in our head
it's also tough because you're taking a
cartoon turn into real life
I like the CG I don't like blue face you
know like blue face III find blue face
offensive but I the blue brain groups
like what the [ __ ] exactly what the [ __ ]
you guys what about the Blue Man Group
first of all the exactly well they're
people I think I think it works it might
be good hate might be Will Smith doesn't
mistrust me if you did this he's gonna
knock you out
yeah him now is gonna be as good as
Robin Williams of course not but he's he
might it's been Rob lives we die hard
you just gotta go down different lengths
yes scary or differently it's like with
Heath Ledger like is [ __ ] how they
say they was walking Phoenix and be as
good as Heath Ledger's Joker completely
different very different yeah I think
it's gonna be I think Joaquin Phoenix
from what the little I saw is going to
surprise the [ __ ] out of a lot of people
I assume it's give me yeah what do you
think he's another guy just Renato yeah
if he does some yeah Will Smith does not
miss thing but Will Smith enough - [ __ ]
he was a Latin let me look at it let me
see
alright this makes sense yeah yeah I'll
be the first one to buy a ticket
well I think that Joe como he's gonna be
pretty [ __ ] yes oh yeah
so Bob Costas for last year's Superbowl
he was supposed to do the cotton
commentating is it
it's just commentating yeah he's been on
every Super Bowl in like forever but
then he kept saying stuff about
concussions you know how bad like the
sports football right now the reality is
people get life-changing concussions
yeah and obviously NBC is like either
sponsored I have contracts with the NFL
so Roger Goodell right seven billion
dollars yeah yeah and Roger Goodell is
the guy who it's like no no that NBC if
it play that so Brian has the back
there's another clip that's even better
play the clip for it's possible to say
football is an exciting sport but there
are these undeniable problems the issue
that is most substantial
the existential issue is the nature of
football itself and so it was that one
year ago just weeks before he was to
host his seventh and final Superbowl Bob
Costas was removed from the telecast how
convenient
the NFL is not handoff to fall apart on
November 7 2017 at a symposium in
Maryland the reality is that this game
destroys people's brains Costas is
comments when twill burns all an NBC who
is that current contract with the NFL is
worth roughly nine billion dollars
quickly distanced itself from its star
Bob's opinions are his own and they do
not represent those the NBC Sports Group
so I guess that NBA is not sure whether
there's a connection between football no
no of course not posit channel of course
they know that the remit like there's
gonna be there's give me issues when
you're playing football
everyone's you have issues when they get
older it's just everyone knows this yeah
if you're Bob Costas and he's an
employee of NBC and they've put seven
billion dollars not in the business or
whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah yeah no
[ __ ] no oh you're you you just can't
keep preaching how it's terrible for
people to play football no I can't have
I think he's just telling the truth and
he's just expressing an opinion but I
don't I actually would never have kicked
him off of it I think he's excellent
what he does I don't think it takes away
from it I think it's something we all
know we're all dealing with and I think
the worst thing you can do is not talk
about it or keep it under foot it's
everywhere yeah but a little bit but you
also paid to hold on but yeah you pay
him and then chin did you did you
recognize he was gone from the Super
Bowl of course not but you know no I
didn't know but what I think we're doing
something films like oh we'll find
someone else yeah but I think he'll
create problems for us and this is our 9
billion dollars investment all he's
doing is stating the fact right I think
when you're stating facts you should be
allowed to do that because we all know
that and he's just stating the facts and
he's going this is he's raising
questions that all of us have anyway so
I don't think I don't mind it I think I
think the NFL I don't mind either no I
don't mind it but if I'm Roger Goodell
or if I'm Dana White yeah there's a guy
keeps talking [ __ ] about the UFC like a
window someone else I'm liking in
question is you pay him - is he talking
[ __ ] or is he just raising things that
we are already talking about that little
fighter says we're underpaid I deserve
more and I'm getting brain trauma uh
that's then that's all true all right
yeah yeah but we're not gonna promote
you to main event if that's all you're
gonna keep talking they're there
although there is the question wrong
yeah you are you are running a business
and if somebody is reminding the fans of
things you don't want them to remind of
it is the NFL's prerogative right
they're allowed to do whatever that's
what I'm saying I'm not saying this is
right yeah I'm saying if I'm Roger
Goodell I'm like yeah get rid of that
guys I as I was I think about it you
know that the whole knee the football
thing and you're not allowed to like me
you know the whole thing the NFL decided
you're not allowed to taking me you
could stay in the locker room but you
know that Stan for me and as I as I
think about that I would have I would
never would have made that a big deal I
would have said I would have said we're
gonna sing the national anthem if you
want to take a knee take a knee you know
it's not my business it's this country's
actually founded on the idea that you
can take a knee not stand do whatever
you want and that's what the flag
actually stands for so [ __ ] it I mean
that's how I would have handled it and
there but again like you said it's a
private organization you're you can
choose not to watch the NFL as a result
of that but I think the NFL are a bunch
of smart people and they're like you
know what juice is worth the squeeze
this is a decision it's a corporate
decision we made it may not be popular
maybe it's not right in the eyes of some
people like myself it doesn't really
matter what was the same way I watched
when the Reebok deal happens do you have
seen ice cap talking [ __ ] about the
Reebok deal non-stop they're like and I
want to work for the UFC they went oh no
well no dude yes we knew Kim put you on
our broadcast team and you're talking
[ __ ] about our new deal and I went oh
that makes right I was like this is
ridiculous I'm telling the truth
do we get that yeah we're paying you
you're not part of our team anymore nope
yep no we're paying you we can pay
anyone do it we're not gonna pay you
when you have these even though they're
true this isn't what we're trying and
you made that choice you were like I'm
sorry Bob part about it yeah there's
gonna be some and if you did that's how
I feel about all everything like if you
want to make this if you want to make
these choices let's
get really controversial if you want to
be a transgender person you may be in a
position where there are no bathrooms
for you it might be a situation if I as
a female maybe you'll go in there but
whatever but also if you are a man who
is now a woman you you have to be ready
and take responsibility for the fact
that some people might be a little
uneasy about you going into bathroom
with their daughter
because some people like well what what
stage is this person in the pre-op
position these are questions that you
have to take responsibility for - it's
not everybody else's responsibility it's
like whatever you decide to do there are
ramifications good and bad you know
Colin Kaepernick took a knee not playing
anymore big price to pay big [ __ ]
price makes more money correct yeah but
then again you know silver lining making
more money look at me thank you more
money
exactly but it's gutsy and sometimes
backfires I'm doing worse sometimes
doesn't work out but I'm such a fan of
that I mean it's like take personal
responsibility and sometimes when you
make the moral stand on something or
whatever comes with a real price but
that booth Bob Casas I think he's doing
what he should now if you're gonna take
that stand and you get negative response
from the big from the man you better you
need to run with it don't go quiet now
if I'm Bob Costas I'm doing this 30
you're going hard in the paint you girl
you gotta you're gotta go all-in
well they say we jegos like my bad I was
wrong actually football super safe
please let me back nope nope nope
he said regret it all Steve you stayed
you stay truthful if that's what you
believe in yeah yeah what else you got
do you want to see when Jerry gets cut
off even though you mentioned it you
want to watch it yeah Brian and seen it
sure alrighty
and that's not the quote she's very
pretty
which one
[Music]
and the first topic paper in this
history when I actually what I thought
it was for a second so I'd like that
that's really nice because when they
they my brother this year I want to take
this opportunity while I'm here to just
talk to all of the kids that are
watching this that are inspired to do
music all my peers that may use it from
their heart that do things appear to
tell the truth I'm gonna let you know we
play a sport not a fax from the basis or
so it's not the NBA where at the end of
the year you know they're talking
potentially make the right decisions for
what the games this is a this is a
business where sometimes you know it on
it's up to a bunch of people that might
not understand you know what a big
straight kitchen Candida has to say or
[Applause]
anybody else or brother from Houston
right there my brother Travis look the
point is you've already won if you have
people who are singing your songs word
for word if their hero in your home
[Applause]
what a great [ __ ] speech in that
great I agree with that
what a great speech and they kind of off
like that I see I don't know but here's
the thing I don't think it because he's
not anti Grammy just like this doesn't
matter you guys are still killing it's a
trying win what's not trying yeah but
it's a shout out to people of artists
everywhere who might be toiling and
obscurity or toiling in a smaller venue
and he's like take heart well he's
saying if you only saying if you're the
hero in your hometown your people are
buying tickets just show you don't need
this group they're coming out in the
snow and the rain then yeah if you're
selling out the theater yeah but no not
just that he's saying yeah I was like
Jackson but I don't have a controversy
here because they cut everyone off and
he got his message out you know watch
everyone they cut everybody out there
you're tight on time yes yeah and he
gets all that there was a big applause
break in there like that's it they
literally cut every everyone got cut off
yeah Alicia Keys was by far the biggest
best performance of the night really see
it no Oh two pianos she's playing both
the same time singing mm-hmm look it up
chin it's amazing and then she goes she
goes through the hits all the hits and
sings him better than all the originals
she goes she's playing she goes you ever
wish she wrote these songs she goes I do
and then start singing me like holy [ __ ]
play that one only 30 seconds her son is
incredibly talented to keep scrolling
down made beats for Kendrick there you
go it really you know little boy you
ready for
it's four languages because she's so
talented and
[Applause]
such as from the skies living room but
what it is there's not a better one chin
what about what we were just watching or
is that just who's a better
she's soaked watching us do all the
Oh
Jeff Scott's performances he's terrible
compared to this
[Music]
and she and the with shields but I did
write this song it does the New York on
its shoulder
excuse me chills
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean I'd somebody listen I can't take
it was so great cuz she didn't know she
was although song is so great she was
but there is one I wrote and hit that
New York this is the thought she would
[Music]
cool hat - she's kind of perfect right
her pretty my wrong pretty perfect
I mean she's perfect like she's
something else sighs I mean what thefuck
by far the best part of the Grammys JLo
performed she did a Motown tribute it
was so awkward she's not good she's not
good she's good she's not as a singer
he's pretty good but here's the thing
here's where it gets awkward
well it's Motown yeah so why would you
have a girl from the Bronx a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Latin girl performing out of all
the people to do it it was so awkward
yeah that's awkward what else he had
chin well related to that that childish
gambino Donna Glover it's the first time
that a rap song ever one song of the
year so he made history with his song
that's it really you know this is
America
is it really rap song and plus it sounds
a lot like a like someone said they'd be
jacked it from him yeah hit a problem
right we haven't been saying you ripped
it off but I don't know if it's a rap
song I don't know what else you put it
on there but oh this bloody one yeah I
like it a lot and then this is him with
a blond beard but black guys are doing
this you see Antonio Brown died his
mustache I don't know why they're doing
it I wonder why they're doing it obvious
this whole world is weird that looks
terrible it's just this new look fashion
it might be for something though as he's
always doing something yeah all right it
happened remember in the lot last time
we talked about a nurse impregnating a
patient and you guys said that it
probably happens all the time somewhere
what happened again with this guy and
the woman was intellectually disabled
she has a brain of a child Jesus Christ
so he was actually they did
investigations and then he didn't turn
in his DNA he didn't submit to a DNA
test but in April 2 of this last year
they actually asked if that girl if
anything happened and she did a report
saying he touched me inappropriately and
that gave him enough evidence to test
his DNA and then found out it was him
now so the girl has a mental issue does
the baby come out with mental issues I
don't know is that I think so
I don't think so there because people
give birth when you're perfectly fine
you give birth to people that have
mental issues right yeah but if you have
doubts and let's say you have Down
syndrome I think the chances of the baby
having downstairs rooms like 80 percent
or something like that oh yeah there's
some bro sites right now I looked at I'm
pretty sure i watch a show born this way
on TLC yeah and they always want to have
like a regular life and they say how
they won't have kids and the parents
like can't have kids so if it's to down
syndrome yeah you cannot do that not a
good idea
[Music]
35 to 50 percent chance feature set
chance their baby will have down Sam
yeah Wow not terrible I mean high rods
for sure but it's a really high on 50%
just wanted to I'll put in Russian
Roulette well that's that's half it's
that's Dawa well it's a shame what else
we got alright so this pregnant lady
went to a Jamaican bakery and then she
wanted these Jamaican patties right and
they sold out that day
so she got an argument it came back with
a bat and started smashing all their
windows if I was young girl to smashed
all the windows of PF Changs last night
I've had one PF Changs we ordered it
from post mates it came two hours later
yeah my dad was starving he came to ours
angry post might think about [ __ ] we
have changed and give a [ __ ] off dude
the food was cold poor Baba didn't eat
all day God so I get this lady's
frustration let me see her break these
ghetto windows an irate bat wielding
pregnant woman smashing the windows
that's hard work she's hormonal 100 she
want these beef patties in the Bronx the
owner says the beef was over Jamaican
beef patties the bakery had just run out
and they asked the woman to wait 15
she's a regular they made more she was
arguing screaming hello hello so finally
another employee ran to the front yeah
15 minutes
they said to her miss may I help you and
she said yeah the other lady said
there's no beef patties why the hell is
there no beef patties excuse my language
she started cursing what you know
obscene words the owner Simone Johnson
didn't want to be on camera says the
woman while she doesn't know her name is
a regular customer this all happened on
January 15th fatback that's pretty much
it I mean when I get it
that's pretty hardcore we're showing the
best of pfj any windows then sometimes
you get a bachelor I eat them good you
know yeah yeah you know you should bash
in what I don't know where to go with
that nothing my creation I own face let
me bash your face in
I like a beef patty I like that I'll
bash your face in how's that sound so
aggressive how about I bash him till
send that to people who tell people in
Palm Beach if they don't come to show
you're gonna bastard hey if you don't
come to my show if you're if you live in
Florida I mean we live in Alabama you
live anywhere near Florida you don't
come to my show at West Palm Beach this
weekend Thursday Friday Saturday I'm
gonna bash your faces in yes all right
you can get tickets go to my Instagram
or tea fat K calm [ __ ] in - otherwise
he's gonna bash it if you want to walk
around with a bashed in face don't come
to my [ __ ] up in this show Florida
that's all of Florida and then if you're
in Miami to Florida again James Brian
and bash your face and good enough well
you're up cuz I'm in [ __ ] Miami
yeah and I'm not gonna bash any faces
but I'll think about yes if you didn't
kind of my show March 16th to the 18th
Miami Improv y'all yeah - your face and
yep bash bash and nuts
match March 16th through 17th we're
Bastion nuts in our mouths Miami improv
March 15 through the 16th after I'm in
Washington DC
I'm bashing more butts and nuts I'm in
Washington DC March 28th through the
30th get your tickets t fat cake on
Quincy Brown town this weekend Palm
Beach this if I kid we're out